you
[Music]
I'm a law professor I'm one of the only
law professors I think in the room I
remember a god who wasn't give gave a
talk calm Alan Lloyd gave a talk at
Stanford once when I was there and he
didn't have powerpoint and he said
doesn't use PowerPoint because power
corrupts with PowerPoint corrupts
absolutely and so he never in everything
right so max asked me to report back on
the law and policy development since the
Puerto Rico conference two years ago and
Max I'm going to do that I promise but
before I do that I want to take you back
even further all the way back to the
1980s we can imagine right and in the
1980s as today there was a lot of
excitement around artificial
intelligence people were really
interested in fact it's been become
fashionable among the sort of snarky ER
tech journalists to compare headlines
from the 1980s with headlines from today
like you could make a game about it you
know mean like this is an actual
headline I'm going to read you from the
New York Times a robot is after your job
right is that headline from 2016 or is
it from 1986 right big companies like
General Electric or 80s google as i like
to call them bought up bought up AI
companies in the past people in this
room will tell you that the basic
algorithms and systems that are
supporting a I today I better bet I've
been available since at least the 1970s
if not if not earlier so how is now
different and how do we know that it's
different and when I'm going to tell you
standing up here as a law professor its
I think we know from the seriousness of
the policy response okay so here's my
case for that in 1961 John it meant when
john f kennedy was elected they were
calls for him to hold a conference about
robots in labor he didn't do that ok
later they were calls to form a federal
automation commission and a Department
of Science and Technology neither were
formed now you might be thinking well
there was OTA office of Technology
Assessment that was 1972
there was the office of science
technology policy for the White House
that was 1976 I looked and I found no
hearings on artificial intelligence in
the House or Senate leading up to the
so-called AI winter and indeed senator
Cruz characterized in November 30th 2016
commerce science and transportation
hearing on AI as Congress's first ever
hearing focused solely on artificial
intelligence okay now it turns out that
over the summer house commerce had had
an advanced robotics hearing in August
of 2016 you know lyin Ted and all that
but I think he's pretty much accurate
there's never really been a actual
hearing focused on artificial
intelligence in fact most of the
discussion of high-tech in the 19th
high-tech was what we used to call cyber
in the 1980s it was what we call cyber
today with high-tech then was basically
about whether we can safely divest in a
basic research without Japan gaining too
much of an ad jamas now I found one
example in my research 1985 the
now-defunct OTA office of Technology
Assessment had artificial intelligence
as one case study in in critical trends
and issues in our own research and
development but since the Puerto Rico
conference the White House itself has
held a series of four workshops on
artificial intelligence and it published
a request for information in the Federal
Register an official request for people
to give feedback to the White House one
of the most powerful visible
organizations in the world and it's not
just the United States you know I've
spoken to officials in Japan I've
testified before the German parliament
recently what the bundestag is is as
it's called there are many many efforts
spinning up all over the place so in
short policymakers at the highest levels
are taking me I very seriously and I
think that's different i think that's
evidence that today is is different okay
so max i will do what you asked i will
summarize the policy related reports in
the last couple of years so first let's
start with just the Obama administration
help series of four workshops
some of us in this room participated
heavily in those issued a series of
reports one is called preparing for the
future of artificial intelligence that
was in October of 2016 I'm not going to
summarize the entire long report 54
pages or whatever it is take a look but
I pulled out a couple of quotes I
thought were interesting one of which is
government has an important role to play
in the advancement AI of AI through
research and development and growth of a
skilled diverse workforce another is
that ethical training for AI
practitioners and students is a
necessary part of the solution this is
my favorite one may be my favorite quote
from all the reports from all over the
White House but it's just a beautiful
sentence adapting gracefully to
unforeseen situations is difficult yet
necessary for say pop safe operation
right they talk about cybersecurity they
talk about weapons systems it's a great
report and i really recommend it if you
haven't looked through it separately a
few months later on the white house
issued a separate report on the economy
called artificial intelligence
automation in the economy quote a i
should be welcome for its potential
economic benefits these benefits however
will not necessarily be evenly
distributed across society this report
advocates strategies to educate and
prepare new workers to enter the
workforce cushion workers who lose jobs
and keep them attached to the labor
force and finally to combat inequality
another effort that came out that's not
much discussed but actually is closest
to some of the things that fli thinks
about is this research and development
plan that came out at the same time in
october 2016 it's called the National
artificial intelligence research and
development plan and in many ways this
comes you know the closest to the
conversation we're having today this is
informed not just by the White House
workshops but also by a workshop that um
James Kufner then at Google now at
Toyota and I put together for the
National Science Foundation and the
Department of Homeland Security just a
couple of quotes for that to give you a
flavor we expect a I technologies to
behave
according to the formal and informal
norms to which we hold our fellow humans
quote before AI systems are in
widespread use assurance is needed that
these systems will operate in a safely
and securely in a control well defined
and well-understood manner and in those
words you can hear a lot of the kinds of
values going to be talking about over
the next couple of days separately some
of the individual hosts of the workshops
like folks here like Kate Crawford and
Meredith Whittaker actually published
their own reports in connection to their
own workshops and the one that I would
recommend taking a look at is from sep
tember of 2016 AI now workshop that was
the last workshop which was in july
seven in new york city i won't get into
great detail there it's a relatively
short pretty accessible document but it
has four key themes which are healthcare
labor inequality and ethics so then
moving beyond just the Obama that was
just the Obama administration right
moving beyond that a number of other
important institutions have to begun to
tackle these issues Kate first
Butterfield is here from the I Triple E
the Institute of electoral Electrical
and Electronics Engineers they have a
great document along comprehensive
document that they put out that's called
ethically aligned design its purpose is
to preserve and promote I'm totally
gonna mispronounce this eudaimonia Peter
do I have eudaimonia right is that you
don't you know maiya okay thank you very
much yes but it means flourishing and
the idea is to promote flourishing in
light of advances in and widespread
distribution of AI systems one of the
quotes I pulled out of their summary
document is we strongly believe that
values based design methodology should
become an essential focus for the modern
organization they also had a specific
committee a subcommittee devoted to law
and policy that was led up by John
havens and Derek jinxin and k i'll pull
a quote from that which I like a lot
there is much to do for lawyers in this
field that is thus far attracted very
few practitioners and academics despite
being an area of pressing need and part
of I like that because it explains why
you get stuck with me for an
now until smarter people end up going
into this into this area then there was
the Stanford on artificial intelligence
100 something that was funded by Eric
orbits and his wife and at Stanford is a
long-term study of artificial
intelligence the point of that was to
assemble expert diverse expert panels
over every few years every five years or
so and they assembled the inaugural
panel it was chaired by Peter stone at
Texas and we issued a report and I Eric
was on this panel and some of the other
people in this room were on this
inaugural panel as well and I was as
well some of the quotes I want to point
out as a society we are under investing
resources in research on the societal
implications of AI technologies as the
transform of technology AI is the
potential to challenge any number of
legal assumptions in the short medium
and long term the report happens to
single out the following privacy
innovation policy civil liability
criminal liability the law of agency
certification labor and politics itself
one thing I love about the document that
we made is that it has this really great
short history of AI as an appendix and
so for those of you are a little less
familiar I'd take a look at that this
year we s now last year we updated the
US road map to robotics which is a very
influential document it gets together
all the major big major labs in the
united states that do robotics research
all the heads of those labs get together
and tell congress what you know where
the pathway is forward and this year we
actually added or added back i suppose a
law section that covered a bunch of
different issues and and many more right
and so you know there really has been a
tremendous amount that has come out in
the last couple of years that's just
with by the way within the United States
this is happening at a national and
international level as well just to give
you a couple examples of that the EU
Committee on legal affairs assemble the
Commission on civil law rules on
robotics and in May of 2016 they issued
a report which is interesting for what
it for what it covers a bit in
conversation with the Japanese Ministry
of Economy Trade and Industry which
actually spun up in July of 2015 a
robotics policy office these things are
happening all over the world and at the
highest levels okay so I don't want to
speak for this community I mean I'm up
here summarizing but I have had a front
see that a lot of these conversations
have been involved in most everything
I've mentioned here and a few other
things and so I wanted to offer some of
the public interventions that have seen
a lot of consensus okay so these are the
kinds of recommendations we're seeing
come up again in multiple documents and
don't seem to be terribly controversial
right number one there should be more
expertise in artificial intelligence in
government right why did the White House
do a series of four workshops on AI why
did they get it so why did they do so
well and so deeply well because they had
ed Felton who is a PhD in computer
science and a professor of computer
science at Princeton who was really you
know behind that effort really fueling
that ever that was something we saw
again and again that the government
should continue to invest in basic and
applied AI research and that that
research should be in a disciplinarian
nature should cover societal impacts and
so forth this is an interesting one that
you may not have thought about
necessarily but the government should
remove actual and perceived barriers to
research such as the threat of a lawsuit
under the Digital Millennium Copyright
anti-circumvention provision or the
Computer Fraud and Abuse Act for people
who try to reverse-engineer and study
and unpack algorithms and machine know
and systems that are not available to
the public so if you're doing research
trying to figure out why is this
decision being made by an algorithm why
is this system behaving the way it does
you know you don't want to run afoul of
these proceed barriers to research as
you're doing it have
company who doesn't like the result sue
you over the fact that you have violated
their copyright somehow or violated a
federal law another thing we saw come up
a lot is that we need to have a set of
safety thresholds and develop standard
techniques to validate safety I mean
this by itself by the way is a
absolutely non-trivial problem in order
to the defects you almost everybody flew
here I imagine right and the Federal
Aviation Administration has a whole
apparatus around making sure the plane
is safe and for mission critical aspects
of you know for things that are actually
critical to the safe operation of the
plane they make you certify that to tend
to the minus 9 probability of an adverse
event during a natural lifespan of the
technology right that is a very very
high threshold what is the appropriate
threshold for releasing an algorithm on
the stock market what even is the
appropriate threshold for a self-driving
car right and then once you set that
appropriate threshold you figure out
that balance between safety and
efficiency and everything else how do
you validate that the claim is true how
do you ask whether or not that has
actually been met these are very
difficult and as yet unsolved issues
another big one is we need to manage the
displacement of labor even if things
turn out to turn out to be better in the
long run right i mean even the National
Economic Council you know obviously I
heard Jason give a bunch of different
chairperson of that give a bunch of
different talks much more optimistic
than Eric and some others are I suppose
at one level I suppose he's cautiously
optimistic but he really really thinks
we not only do we should we not be
worried about AI but we really need to
invest in AI we're going to fall behind
not Japan this time but China and Russia
but at the end of the day they
acknowledge that that it won't fall
evenly across society and that we need
to manage it we need to be more vigilant
about racial gender and other bias we
need to get a handle on privacy there
needs to be meaningful human control
over hey I enabled weapons these are
some of the consensus things that in the
last two years of really emerged
I really emerged um now last thing I'll
say is that you know Kate Crawford and I
in a recent piece for nature identified
some of the gaps in what we were seeing
in that in the law and policy
conversation for example not just
thinking about how AI gets deployed when
it does but where it gets deployed and
for whom one interesting observation
that that we mentioned in the nature
piece is that I'm trying to say this in
a sensitive way the very same people it
seems who say were never we shouldn't be
worried about the existential threat of
artificial intelligence we shouldn't be
worried about super intelligence and the
reason that we shouldn't be worried
about super intelligence is because it's
in its infancy you know it's like held
together by duct tape it's like you know
and we just so much we don't know we
just were so far away from that we
shouldn't be worried about it one quote
I've always liked is we should be
worrying about it as much as we should
be worrying about overpopulation on Mars
right those very same people then often
will turn around and say you know but
but we should begin immediately to apply
artificial intelligence in some of our
most sensitive vulnerable societal
contexts like health care and education
right and so there's a sense that even
today artificial intelligence gains and
benefits are not being evenly
distributed across society and that some
portion of our society especially the
vulnerable are having adverse decisions
being made that they find inscrutable
and they have no means by which to
challenge I can see interest of set by
my remarks we can talk about that later
but the point that matter is is that
this is a parody I mean at the end of
the day nobody of course wants AI to
work poorly everybody wants AI to
fulfill its great promise to deliver on
the many many many potential benefits
that it has but I do think that and Kate
and I wrote about this you know we do
need to to make sure it's falling in
ways that are even
okay so obviously there are a lot more
challenges ahead and I'm out of time but
this is a lot this is a lot for two
years right I mean you know I'm not
obviously correlation is not causation I
don't know that we can talk about the
Puerto Rico conference as being
responsible for all the things that
happen right but at a minimum it's
incredibly good timing and and so with
that I'll turn it over to you or to your
questions thank you very much so you
know you know when people ask me of
Andrews you suppose doing research and
x4 almost as every value of x my answer
is yes right except with a biological
weapons or some really horrible things
like that so do I support research and
say nai yes but i think the mall there's
a question I have to ask my team this is
a welder limited resources how much do I
invest in say the trolley problem and
how much i invested losing control of AI
versus how much do i invest in so
driving cause we should safety thousand
dollars a day when we get there versus
how much to reinvest in AI for health
care which will save even more than
3,000 dives a day and i think that one
of the operational health care is
mentioned health care is you know
frankly the barclays oh right it's not
that we need to 99 the one of the start
saving lives we just need to do better
than you know the average human doctor
and then we'll keep getting better from
there and I think we're already seeing
those benefits to society by many
companies ya know and by the way you
know this about me but I completely
agree that is to say i think that the
focus should be on improving what we
have and that AI is extremely
well-positioned to do that i will say
that in my canvassing the law and policy
developments of the last couple years
it's fair to say that the kinds of
conversations that are happening are not
happening at the level of existential
threat yet right i mean that's not
what's happening you know i mean and
what not i SAT through for a lot of
conversation in the last couple of years
and really it's about you know how do we
introduce this powerful and beneficial
and important technology in a way that
is
that is beneficial in the near term so
that's not the conversation necessarily
at the at least at the US federal level
who knows what the future may bring it's
only been two years I wanted you to
comment on any parallels between this
area and regulation in the biotech area
which has been at the 40 years and of
course famously started with the
conference actually held here in a
cinema in nineteen seventies could you
comment on that yeah I mean so um I'm
limited in my ability to comment by two
things one that biotechnology is not my
area of expertise and two that you know
1980s is about as far as back as I go
and so but I of course I'm familiar with
the story right and so the idea there
would be that a bunch of people got
together and said there are some
fundamental concerns we have around
certain kinds of techniques in
bioengineering let's hit the pause
button let's make sure that when we go
forward we're doing so within an ethical
framework and I think that's been very
very positive very beneficial and I
think now you know coming from Silicon
Valley biotechnology of course is a huge
part of our of our sector but i think
it's behaving more it's going forward
more responsibly as in light of that
early intervention please yes but just
rather enough it worked very well back
then when it was a few people involved
but in the case of biotech it probably
doesn't work now when its global and
when it's so easy the entry level is
falling and so one wonders whether
that's going to be a similar threat here
it could be it could be and I can
certainly offline recommend people that
write deeply in that space just quickly
what I'm sorry to interrupt but the
original is similar Solamar conferences
I remember I my old enough to have been
here but I've read a bit about it was
around the safety concerns for the air
we sorry for the biotech weeds recruits
themselves which is really what
crystallized the energy it wasn't
embroider ethical set of issues it was a
very concrete specific set of protocols
that came out of a civil war that were
then adopted by the NIH CDC and other
government agencies so I think was a
very different set of issues that were
wrestling fair enough ken thank you very
much for that question so over the last
day i was almost 50 years
the tech community has been very
successful in finding of any attempt at
regulation arguing it will stifle
innovation and so it makes you look at
the ADIZ you know maybe the FCC I mean a
very minor places with a some regulation
of technology in general now you look at
the larger starting five you know the
top five corporations I think for them
for other cybertek it's a you sector of
the economy huge influence on life do
you see any any possible any at any
thinking about maybe time to change this
attitude of a kind of less affair and
start regulating technology well you
know that's a that will have a longer
discussion about this right of course in
our session on law let me just take off
my summary hat here and just put on my
own and eosin cratic a professor hat I
think that's that's a misunderstanding I
mean dick the area of privacy for
example you know of the largest social
media platforms and you know the big
Internet giant's virtually every single
one of them is in a 20-year consent
decree with the Federal Trade Commission
where they have to have independent
audits and they have to check in you
know we have net neutrality rules
governing information for now governing
information communications technologies
that are incredibly important we have
regulations like the computer the
Communications Decency action section
230 which immunizes user you know
platforms what users doing those
platforms all of which have been engines
of innovation and so I do think that the
technology sector is regulated it's not
regulated in the same sort of classic
way we think about certain things but
they definitely operate within you know
restraints now whether we need to
ratchet that up maybe so I mean privacy
is an area that has stalled in large
measure because of an unwillingness to
pursue it both by regulators in the
courts as assertively as it might be and
so there's always opportunities to tweak
and ratchet but i would just myself
quibble with the characterization that
that because of a pro innovation mindset
we just haven't regulated that at all
maybe in fact we'll see that in the
coming administration where everything
is pulled back
and that's going to be a natural
experiment right thank you yep thank you
very much thanks everybody
[Applause]
[Music]